ABOUT MEETING WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WE HAVE A MEMBER OF THE HOUSE
INTEL COMMITTEE REVIEWING THAT
REDACTED AND UNREDACTED VERSIONS
AND HE JOINS US TO TELL US WAS
INSIDE.
THE MEMOS DESCRIBED FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR COMEY'S PRIVATE
INTERACTIONS WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE BIG QUESTION IS, WHETHER
COMEY LEAKED ANY CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION TO THE PRESS.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID A SHORT TIME
AGO, AFTER THE MEMOS WERE MADE
PUBLIC.
>> I'M SURE THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
IS CONSIDERING MY RECOLLECTION
OF THOSE EVENTS.
WHICH WERE REFLECTED IN THOSE
MEMOS.
IT IS MY RECOLLECTION THAT IT'S
THE EVIDENCE THAT WILL BE USED.
THESE WOULD BE TO SHOW THAT I
WROTE IT DOWN AT THE TIME, SORT
OF THE BOLSTER TO CREDIBILITY MY
RECOLLECTION.
>> Laura: MUST BEEN LT
>> Laura: MUST BEEN LS
>> Laura: MUST BEEN LB
>> Laura: MUST BEEN LI
>> Laura: MUST BEEN LG
>> Laura: MUST BEEN LN
CONGRESSMAN CHRIS STEWART, A
MEMBER OF THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE.
GIVE US YOUR TAKE.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT IT SHOWS ME,
DIRECTOR COMEY WAS DISHONEST
WITH THE PRESIDENT FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING AND CONTINUES TO BE.
HE SHOULD HAVE GONE IN AND
INSTEAD, MR. PRESIDENT, WE HAVE
THIS PIECE OF POLITICAL GARBAGE
THAT WAS FUNDED BY THE DNC,
HILLARY CLINTON, PAY NO
ATTENTION TO IT.
IF ANYONE BRINGS IT UP, WE'LL
REFUTE IT AND SAY IT'S NOT
CREDIBLE.
HE SAID LATER ON IT WAS
SALACIOUS AND UNVERIFIED.
INSTEAD, WHAT HE SAID TO THE
PRESIDENT IS, THE RUSSIANS ARE
REPORTING, AS IF THIS WAS A
CREDIBLE RUSSIAN INTELLIGENCE
OPERATION, HE KNEW THAT IT
WASN'T.
HE KNEW THAT THIS WAS NOT SOME
FORMAL DOCUMENT THE RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE HAD CREATED AND PUT
TOGETHER.
IT WAS PUT TOGETHER BY
HILLARY CLINTON, THE DNC.
HE USED A FOREIGN AGENT, BY THE
WAY, WHO USED SECOND AND THIRD
HAND INFORMATION FROM
UNIDENTIFIED RUSSIANS.
WE  HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN HONEST W
WE  HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN HONEST T
WE  HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN HONEST H
THE PRESIDENT.
BY THE WAY, HE'S BEING DISHONEST
WITH THE PRESIDENT CONTINUALLY.
HE SAYS HE THINKS IT'S POSSIBLE
THE PRESIDENT IS UNDER SOME TYPE
OF SHADOW, THAT THE RUSSIANS
HAVE A --
>> Laura: HE KIND OF WALKED A
HAVE WALKED IT BACK.
>> Laura: THAT WAS OUTRAGEOUS.
>> THEY COULD HAVE INFORMATION
ON YOU, ME, DIRECTOR COMEY.
THAT IS THE DIRECTION HE HAS
TAKEN, HE IS TRYING TO CAST AS
DEEP A SHADOW AS HE POSSIBLY
COULD OVER THIS.
>> Laura: MEMOS TO THE FILE
ARE INVARIABLY SELF-SERVING
DOCUMENTS.
I REMEMBER WHEN I WAS A WHITE
COLLAR CRIMINAL DEFENSE
ATTORNEY, YOU ALWAYS LOOK AT
THOSE, LET'S GO OVER WHAT REALLY
HAPPENED.
YOU WANT TO WRITE A MEMO TO THE
FILE THAT MAKES YOU LOOK LIKE A
FOOL OR A LIAR OR MAKES YOU LOOK
LIKE YOU ARE MISREPRESENTING THE
FACTS.
YOU WILL WRITE A MEMO TO THE
FILE THAT MEMORIALIZES EVENTS
THAT WILL MAKE YOU LOOK IN THE
BEST FLIGHTS.
THERE WAS AN INTERESTING PART OF
THIS -- ONE OF THESE MEMOS, NOT
VERY LONG.
YOU HAVE THE UNREDACTED --
REDACTED VERSION.
THIS IS WHAT HE SAYS IN ONE OF
THE MEMOS.
HE SAID I HAD DINNER WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN THE GREEN
ROOM AT THE WHITE HOUSE AT
6:30 P.M.
I EXPLAINED THAT HE COULD ALWAYS
COUNT ON ME TO TELL THE TRUTH.
HE SAID I DON'T DO SNEAKY
THINGS.
I DON'T LEAK.
I DON'T DO WEASEL MOVES.
WHAT WAS THAT LEAKING THEM OUT
MUCH OF A COLUMBIA PROFESSOR TO
RELEASE IT TO THE MEDIA?
WAS THAT LEAKING OR TIDDLYWINKS?
>> IT'S NOT THE WAY IN FBI
DIRECTOR SHOULD RESPOND OR
SHOULD ACT.
TO BE HONEST ABOUT IT, LAURA,
THE TESTIMONY THE DIRECTOR HAS
PROVIDED BEFORE THE COMMITTEES
AND CLOSED SESSIONS DOES NOT
COMPORT AT ALL WITH SOME OF THE
THINGS HE IS SAYING PUBLICLY
RIGHT NOW.
>> Laura: YOU CAN DISCUSS THIS
BECAUSE IT A CLOSED SESSION?
IS IT ALREADY OUT THERE?
>> WE HOPE IT WILL BE.
IT SHOULD BE.
THIS IS ANOTHER GOOD EXAMPLE OF
INFORMATION I SHOULD HAVE BEEN
RELEASED TO THE FIRST TIME WE
WHY IN THE WORLD DOES DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE FEEL LIKE IT IS THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTECT THIS
PERSON RATHER THAN THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY TO BE OPEN AND
HONEST WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Laura: ANOTHER PART OF THIS
MEMO WHERE PRESIDENT TRUMP,
RIGHTLY, AS HE DID IN THE
CAMPAIGN, CALLS INTO QUESTION
ANDREW McCABE.
AT THAT POINT, HE SAYS, ABOUT
THIS POINT, HE ASKED ME AGAIN
ABOUT YOUR GUY, McCABE, IT
DOES SOUND LIKE TRUMP.
WHETHER HE WAS GOING TO BE OKAY.
I AGAIN AFFIRMED HIS ABILITY AND
PROFESSIONALISM AND SAID THE
PRESIDENT WOULD COME TO SEE HIM
AT THAT POINT, HE ALREADY KNEW
THAT ANDREW McCABE PROBABLY
HAD SOME PROBLEMS, YET HE WAS
TELLING THE PRESIDENT THAT
McCABE WAS FINE.
>> THAT BRINGS ME TO ANOTHER
QUESTION.
HOW IS IT THAT THE DIRECTOR OF
THE FBI HAD SURROUNDED HIMSELF
WITH WHAT WE KNOW NOW OUR
POLITICAL HACKS?
ANDREW McCABE, LISA PAGE,
OTHERS.
THE FBI IS NOT FULL OF
PROGRESSIVES.
IT'S NOT FULL OF LIBERAL
ACTIVISTS.
YET, THEY ARE AROUND THE
DIRECTOR AND IT SEEMS LIKE HE
HAD SELECTED AN ADVANCED AND
PROMOTED PEOPLE THAT HAD A
DIFFERENT VIEW THAN MANY
AMERICANS.
>> Laura: WILL YOU BRING COMEY
BACK UP?
>> WE SURE HOPE SO.
>> Laura: HOW WILL YOU MAKE IT
HAPPEN?
>> WE WILL REQUEST HIM TO SPEAK
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE, I EXPECT
HE WILL DECLINE.
I CAN'T IMAGINE --
>> Laura: MAYBE YOU SHOULD
HANG IN A GREEN ROOM.
I THINK YOU SHOULD GO TO MSNBC,
I THINK HE HAS A BINKY AND A
SLEEPING BAG.
>> HE'S BEEN PRETTY EFFECTIVE AT
SELLING HIS BOOK, NO DOUBT ABOUT
IT.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT HIS BOOK.
THIS IS ABOUT LEARNING THE TRUTH
AND HAVING HIM BE ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THE THINGS HE SAID.
AGAIN, I DON'T EXPECT HE WILL BE
BANGING ON OUR DOOR BUT IF HE
DOESN'T, --
>> Laura: WHY WON'T HE?
IS A VERY SMART GUY.
HE WENT TO A CHICAGO LAW SCHOOL,
INCREDIBLE CAREER IN GOVERNMENT.
HE'S A SMART GUY.
IF HE CAN'T WITHSTAND